Watch what you eat. This is a day people play pranks on their family and friends.
You will need: chocolate, garlic, caramel, an onion, a popsicle stick, nuts,...
...a chicken leg, salt, raisins, a toothpaste tube, food coloring and milk.
Step one: Prepare chocolate-covered garlic cloves and pass them off as chocolate-covered peanuts.
Try not to laugh or look suspicious before a prank.
Step two: Make caramel onions instead of caramel apples.
Insert a popsicle stick and add a few nuts on top.
Step three: Sew extra chicken legs on a whole chicken before serving.
Step four: Put salt in someone's water; then sit back and watch their face.
Step five: Stuff raisins into a toothpaste tube and watch people's reaction when they squeeze the tube.
Step six: Switch the bags in your family's cereal boxes for a breakfast surprise.
Step seven: Add a few drops of purple or blue food coloring to someone's milk and serve it with a cookie.
Did you know?
Anthropologists have suggested that practical jokes often function as an effort to bring an outsider into a group.